Russia's President Vladimir Putin
remains absent from the spotlight that
might be welcomed by some G20 member
countries but Putin's war in Ukraine
will still dominate The Summit
would he or wouldn't he
in the end Russia's president decided he
wouldn't as he pulled out of attending
the G20 Summit in person
a blow to Indonesia's president Joko
Widodo who had even traveled to Moscow
to personally invite Vladimir Putin
but many Western members of the G20 will
be relieved they won't have to meet
Putin face to face
some have questioned Russia's membership
following its invasion of Ukraine
an invasion that's created a deep
geopolitical divide
that divide means that even if Putin
isn't on the Indonesian island of Bali
this week his war will still overshadow
events
it's already called turmoil across the
world including a food crisis after
grain prices soared as a result of the
war
a deal to allow grain exports from
Ukraine was agreed with Russia in the
summer but at the end of October Putin
suspended it although cooperation began
a few days later the Russian president
May refuse to extend the deal when the
agreement expires later this week
an energy crisis has also hit the world
hard with most eug20 members doing their
best to reduce their dependence on
Russian gas and oil leaving many out in
the cold
other G20 members including India have
benefited from cheap Russian energy
the knock-on effect of all this has been
rising prices and soaring inflation
G20 members are still divided over
Russia's War
but while it continues its leaders will
struggle to fight its Global effects
or it is Putin's absence being noticed
there ahead of the summit
yeah well I think Ben you know the
dreaded cliche the elephant in the room
of course Vladimir Putin is very much
that elephant here in Bali
um and the war as we've just been
hearing uh very well explained in that
piece very much hanging over things here
I mean I think from the perspective of
here in Southeast Asia which is of
course you know a key kind of center
point of the G20 you know this this
grouping which brings together not just
you know the top table of of global
democracies like the G7 but it it brings
in emerging economies and it brings in
non-democracies you know this this
ideally should be a forum uh where you
know the the kind of you can speak
across the divides of world affairs but
of course the Ukraine war is just a two
deeper divide at the moment and we know
for instance from the German side that
they have been trying to put pressure on
the Chinese side to try to get some kind
of movement from the G20 to try and find
some common language uh on the war on
Ukraine Maybe specifically condemning
the threat of the use of nuclear weapons
but it's very uncertain whether
something like that will come out but I
think to connect to what we've been
talking about between the US and China I
think another fear here in Southeast
Asia that that these divisions over
Ukraine are reflected in the divisions
between the United States and China
there's a risk that the entire world is
sort of stumbling into a new Cold War
scenario where where the more
middle-sized countries the kind of
countries that we're we're seeing
appearing here at the G20 fear that
they're forced to decide which side
they're on their fear they fear that
this will make technological development
Economic Development development all
kinds much more difficult so I think
you'll hear a lot of calls from a lot of
countries here but whatever happens
please let's not let the world get even
more deeply divided than it currently is
Richard Walker at the G20 in Bali where
Joe Biden and Xi Jinping have just met
the and held their high stakes meeting
the American and Chinese presidents and
where the Russian president is not